this is a production of Cornell
University
so welcome everybody to the Cornell Turf
Show this will be our finale for the
spring and you know what started out as
an idea to just talk into the wind in
um for uh during covid to actually keep
people abreast of when they could work
how they could work we had so much so
many things unsure at the time that the
Genesis of this idea uh really was good
and I think we've learned now that
travel schedules and life is back to
post covid it's a little bit tricky both
for Carl and I uh and our guests to do
this so um I but we also know that we
get a lot of feedback from people who uh
don't listen live or watch live but
really enjoy uh catching up on the
podcast or watching the YouTube thing
um that we post every week in fact when
it's not up uh we hear from them uh
almost immediately
um about you know why isn't it up so so
thanks everybody buddy for a wonderful
season this is a week nine of the show
and as you can see in this picture this
is pretty much what a lot of golf course
superintendents and assistants and
assistants in training and anybody who
is an able-bodied person able to read a
water meter or know where the hot spots
on a green are hose dragging has become
has begun now this is incredibly unusual
for us uh in the Northeast at the spring
and the springtime to be dragging a hose
and throw in this much water early and
so you can see many people on the crew
are already hurting this was a tweet
from a golf course superintendent took
his kid to work and between him and the
dog laying on the garage floor I could
not pass this up it was absolutely
depicts what I'm sure many are already
feeling and projecting oh it's going to
be a long season of dragging a hose if
it keeps up like this now
the odd thing is if you've been paying
attention at all the cooler nighttime
what conditions have been keeping the uh
overall temperatures below normal I mean
you can see and it's and it's a really
strong gradient as you go south
significantly cooler eight degrees below
normal in the Delmarva cap BC area and
as you come up it gets a little bit
closer a little bit above normal so you
see you know in Rockland County Orange
County they're a little bit ahead and
out Western New York as well of course
you know to 15 people that live in New
Hampshire Vermont and those two people
that live in Maine Carl they've been
experiencing some uh warmer than normal
conditions but you know the cooler than
normal conditions has been pretty much
related to the cool nighttime
temperatures which I'm sure any golf
course superintendent would tell us is a
welcome relief right I mean if that heat
stress keeps up if you look at our heat
stress map You're simply not seeing the
temperature issues that heat stress
index conditions because the nighttime
temperatures are so cool now again what
seems really odd is the Western and
Northern parts of the region uh have
soil temperatures well above 65 67 some
might even be reporting temperatures in
the 70s in Western New York the Finger
Lakes Region but then as you get down
into the New York metro area Jersey and
South Pennsylvania the Eastern end of
Pennsylvania and of course out to the
cape and along the coast you can see
they're still in the low to mid 50s so a
significant gradient in soil temperature
so you want to keep track of this
because obviously this is going to
govern a lot of what's going on and and
you know what when we often talk about
growth potential right that's the
potential for growth and right now we're
at a pretty high growth potential 80 to
90 percent the potential for growth to
occur however because of the dry
conditions we're simply not getting the
growth so this was uh last week's
rainfall up you know the 17th to the
23rd you can see uh very little rain in
the middle part of this of the region
and and quite a bit of rain towards the
other side now this is more than a week
old uh and it's been pretty dry since
then so if we look at the more recent
data that looks at precipitation minus
of Apple transpiration you see the hard
gradient that's established right around
the DC area Baltimore and DC and south
of there they're getting rainfall but
north of D.C we have we're at two inch
deficits in a single week which means we
didn't get rain and E.T was really high
as as we've seen this past weekend of
course you've seen the grasses started
to dry out now the forecast does not
look good good uh for western parts of
the region Western PA Western New York
West Virginia if you happen to be
listening in eastern Ohio those areas
are going to be extremely dry they're
not going to benefit uh from The rain
that's expected on Saturday and that
rainfall might is likely to be primarily
focused along the coast uh RT gaikano
our climatologist was saying rainfall is
expected to be maybe about inch inch and
a half on Long Island about three
quarters of an inch in New York City and
then degrade as we get up into our
region and if we get a half an inch uh
we'll be lucky uh because as as this
front moves through and a lot of this
has to do with the way the jet stream
has been positioned in fact on our
conference call this morning we heard
that it was warmer in up Upstate New
York this past week than it was in
Atlanta Georgia now anytime you see that
flip-flopping you know there's something
funky going on with the weather now Carl
sent me this beautiful uh map of this
beautiful graph this morning about the
cumulative precipitation and you know
normal precip you know you're you're
right in the 10 inch 10 inches range
maybe 11 inches for the season
last year as everybody remembers we
stayed above normal for much of the
springtime and then it started to dry
out but right now we're two to three
inches behind normal precip and and
while we might get a little bit of rain
on on uh on Saturday it doesn't look
like it's going to give us any more than
a blip so Carl I'm gonna pass it to you
it looks like Dr Serena has joined us uh
welcome Mateo thanks for taking the time
Carl why don't you do your uh discussion
here on water usage yeah so so always
Frank it's a nice little overview of the
weather right the weather is the short
term sort of what we're experiencing
right now and I sort of want to zoom out
to some of the longer term Trends right
the climate and this paper turf grass
and climate change sort of highlights um
how the climate is how we expect the
climate to change and what are the
repercussions for us as uh in the turf
industry so you know Jerry looks through
some of the data and he says one of the
things we're going to see in our sort of
mid-latitudes is uh on an annual is
actually an increase in precipitation
and basically what's going on there is
warmer air just holds more water right
so it doesn't feel like it now with our
current weather we're not getting any
precipitation but uh on the whole we're
probably going to see a little bit more
of that but on the other side we've got
higher temperatures that means increased
evaporative Demand right so higher ET
values that's what we're seeing right
now
um so sort of having to handle both
sides of the water equation too much and
maybe too little and then you look at
these variations uh season to season or
even year to year again we're seeing
that we saw 2021 was a very wet year uh
more much more precipitation than normal
in the last two years right last year
got really dry in the summer we're
already seeing it this spring so that
variation right that's not a great thing
from a superintendent managing right
you've got to handle all the you know
the all the wet all the dry and that's
where infrastructure comes in I was
looking at some of the Mateo's tweets
recently you were doing some irrigation
audits Mateo I got out there last year
did one yesterday actually and it's
really cool data to look at and I would
just say that maintaining your
infrastructure is vital to to handling
this variation right the variation in
water
um if you go back to that graph Rank and
just a couple things to note from our
irrigation audits whenever a head looks
wrong it is wrong in the data so you see
some of these heads here if they're
throwing low if it looks like the the
output isn't good if it's not reaching
the same height as other heads it shows
up in the data either there's more in
certain areas just just these these data
are in inches per 10 minutes right so
you're seeing some areas on green are
getting twice as much irrigation and
then converting that right not everybody
and we've surveyed people Frank right
not everybody knows the inches to the
depth of water to minutes of run time
conversion and we just make a note of
that hey it's probably a good idea to
know hey what does eight minutes get me
is that an eighth of an inch or is that
a 0.08 inches 0.1 right that's an
important thing to know
um and then using data right and this is
something that's very very common I'm
sure we're Mateo you did your work down
in the South and the West Coast right
where water is scarce and a valuable
commodity people use ET data we don't
see that quite as much up here and I
think that's because right we're getting
a lot of precipitation very often and
maybe we're not paying so much for water
but just some of this data I mean we're
getting close to a quarter of an inch a
day reference ET data Frank so if you're
irrigating at say 75 percent of that
that's still
0.18.17 ish yeah and you saw in the map
Carl the map was showing we were at two
inch deficits right yeah so yeah per
week you're getting to almost close to
two inches of a deficit reference CT so
this is good stuff to know hey I should
run my water a certain cycle to
replenish that and then we think of you
know just just basic stuff planning for
Drought years right these drought
emergency plans we've got a little
spreadsheet online fillable right it's
really quick it's just four pages it's
actually a drought and nutrient
management worksheet this is part of our
RIT sustainable golf practices we tried
to make this as simple as possible for
everybody have the information there
fill it out it's it's you know a couple
Pages at the start to sort of explain
what it is and then you see just
basically you know how much are you
going to irrigate what practices are you
going to do when you irrigate and then
there's great tools online like the USGA
water budget calculator so we've been
running this already this spring based
on some of the ET data historical ET
data how much water should you use in
general how many irrigated Acres you can
adjust the ET factors in there that's a
really good tool I think just to sort of
Benchmark your water use and again plan
last year you probably used a little bit
more water than normal in our region
it's probably good to communicate with
your GM your your membership hey if that
happens again if we get 75 percent of
the rainfall that we normally expect
here's how much water I think we're
going to have to use and you have to
budget for that sort of stuff so that
planning I think Frank is is something
we think about and something I'd
encourage everybody to do because it's
it's really not that hard we've tried to
make it easy to use she's got this great
tool to make it easy yeah and I think
it's really useful for everybody yeah
and and of course this is what uh the
grass is starting to look like right
you're starting to see these localized
dry spots Fairways in any areas where
there's stress and limited rooting uh
poor soils conditions right and then you
know if you have the staff you know here
you are doing Greens on the left and
here you got guys you know doing teas
and Fairways on the right with the big
heads moving in the background I mean
this is really predicated on having a
Workforce to do it and again this is
very taxing when you're already doing
this and and if your infrastructure
doesn't work right Carl I thought one of
the more important things you said is
don't wait for a dry year I mean I we've
said for years
these kinds of stress conditions are
going to expose the weaknesses in your
infrastructure and if you have for the
last few years we've exposed weaknesses
in Drainage Systems we've been talking
about drainage last year we had so much
rain we could barely keep up with it and
lo and behold probably everybody
invested in drainage and and of course
what happens we start to get dry weather
so let's take a little bit of a deep
dive as we set it up for Dr Serena to
talk to us a little bit about where all
these great resources that the USGA has
when we look at you know the academic
articles on this the kind of stuff that
Stan koska Mike fedonza Cal Bigelow
Johnny Cesar have been looking at with
critical soil water contents when how
far can you dry these Sands before they
break and become hydrophobic as Stan
Costco would say when when the organic
things in the soil begin a
transformation that turns them from just
normal acids into hydrophobic Coatings
that prevent the soils from re-wetting
effectively now again a great paper that
Mike and Cal and stamp published a
number of years ago really honing in on
this right and and talking about the use
of soil surfactants how these soils
become water repellent where all these
waxes and hydroclobicity characteristics
come from
um and then of course the value of using
soil surfactants here you've got a very
simple graph looking at the depth of the
root Zone where you're not treating it
with a surfactant and it dries down
significantly more uh particularly at
the shallow depths as you get deeper the
differences don't matter as much but
when you're up in the top two inches you
see a significant differences you know
15 20 percent difference in volumetric
water content which is going to show up
as dry spots and so you the use of
surfactants and the wetting agents as we
often call them are something that
generally most people are not thinking
about in April and May in the Northeast
but this would have been a year where
you would have need something like that
now
water use across the country is down
when you look at the gcsa survey from
2005 to 2020 you can see a significant
reduction in the amount of water used on
golf courses down from about you know
2.4 million acre feet to about 1.7
million acre feet and you can see some
of that maybe 30 to 40 percent of that
reduction is simply related to the fact
that there are less irrigated Acres on
the golf courses right some of that is
golf courses closed down some of it is
golf courses took out irrigated grass
now I think this is one of the most
interesting aspects of the entire
discussion because listen you're not
going to meet a golf course
superintendent who doesn't want a dry
Golf Course especially in the
northeastern United States where we
generally have a plethora plethora of
rainfall that creates a problem in the
gcsa water usage survey they said how
receptive are your your golfers to
reduced water use and the changes that
are associated with that now five is
very receptive and if you focus in on
just a Northeast here you see that a
full 40 percent of the respondes the
golf course superintendent said my
golfers are very receptive to me
reducing water use and the changes that
might be associated with that now it's
interesting down in the southwest you
know where dry conditions are typically
more prevalent they seem to be less
receptive now that also could mean
instead of 90 or 100 acres of irrigated
grass now I've only got 70 or 80 and my
ball is going to be in the desert half
the time rather than actually sitting on
any turf grass areas now the thing
that's interesting here is actually
irrigated acreage of golf in the
Northeast has gone up
since 2005 and a lot of that almost all
of that has been associated with more
irrigation in roughs now this is
probably a trend that's very different
than once you get west of the
Mississippi and the 100th Meridian I'm
sure this is a very different story
Mateo but welcome to the show
um Dr Mateo Sereno who I've known for a
number of years through his time at New
Mexico State University is now the
senior manager of irrigation research
and services with the USGA and I'm sure
very much involved in this wonderful
website that the USG has this Water
Resource Center that really has these
great resources and really States the
commitment Mateo about in the next 15
years you're going to invest 30 million
dollars to reduce water use all these
great tools are available there in fact
developing a drought emergency plan much
like we have here for our Northeast golf
courses all of these resources in in one
place and in an article that Mike Kenner
wrote uh in uh the magazine that he
writes for I think is golf industry news
he he I know I've heard you say uh nine
buckets but I thought this thing made a
little more sense 15 years you're gonna
you know resilience Playbook uh
practices that help us use less water
break down the barriers to adoption
including Financial barriers this is a
big one and and water resilient research
and breeding program so Mateo thank you
for taking the time I know it's early on
the on the on Pacific time for you so
talk to us a little bit about your
initiatives with the USGA and the kinds
of things you're starting to look at
right now being only a year uh in the
job you're just getting started there's
a a lot of years ahead of you just
getting started how's it starting to
look for you
well thank you everyone and it's great
to be here
um talking about you know what the uh
USGA is is planning and and wanting to
do so basically you know like this one
it's it's the what generates after our
new CEO mic one decided
um you know he he um put forward one of
these these big pillar one of these big
bold uh leadership initiative and and
one of the first was actually
um the the Water Project you know the
beginning of the water initiative
we're still calling it 15 30 45 which
you've seen uh from the from the slide
you presented the the 15 years 30
million dollars we don't like to talk a
little more a lot about the 45 because
we we get
um golf courses a little scary a little
on that and we got some pushback already
especially here in the southwest where
courses already did so much in the last
20 years to to reduce water use
um
but um the goal is to to drive to keep
drive down
um water use on on golf courses by by 45
and you know I know it's a it's a hefty
goal but you know it's better to
fell short of of high expectation then
don't meet any expectations I couldn't
agree more listen I'm totally in support
and I like when it's stir you know me a
long time I like when it's sort of stirs
thing a little bit but I often do hear
this even in the Northeast Mateo where a
golf course superintendent says Frank
I'm not conservative water because if
they ask me to reduce it I don't want to
use that number from when I've already
conserved I want a big number so 45
percent doesn't hurt as much you know
the game that you know they they have
done a lot turf grass reductions in some
places and of course like this data I
just showed you where we're increasing
the amount of irrigated rough right so
that's got to be concerning what do you
say to the superintendent sort of like
listen I'm afraid to start conserving
now before I'm forced to do it Mateo uh
because then my number will be uh
unmanageable how do you man manage that
conversation with them
so for from our experience what we've
seen it's helpful to start working with
the local water agencies so
um you know we're helping here in in the
Coachella Valley and in the Los Angeles
area where courses you know they started
reducing acreage and getting incentives
for that
um same thing is going to happen in
Arizona pretty soon with the with the
lower
um Basin for the Colorado River so
working with water agencies and having a
track record of what you've done it's
really helpful and in general this Water
Agency uh once they get a once they get
an idea and an estimate they know which
courses they've been doing a good job in
being proactive producing acreage
maintaining the irrigation system versus
you know some of the other they they're
trying to play you know like well I
don't they care or like let me let me
keep my numbers up so when I get asked
to cut by 20 I'm going still going to be
okay yeah
um times times are changing so
it's better to get involved uh and it's
better to stay updated
um don't don't be like um like an
ostrich and drive like your head in the
ground you're hitting this end and
pretend yeah so it's good to hear that
you're getting credit for a period of
time right if you've had a history of
reductions now I know this is a bigger
conversation West in Mississippi and I
know that's where a lot of your focus is
but we can already start to see I don't
I think there's smolders maybe a little
smoke where places on Long Island we're
starting to hear maybe an initiative to
use reclaimed water uh on some of the
golf courses that helps solve actually a
water quality problem on Long Island
where we've got a lot of failing septic
systems a lot of failing Wastewater
systems and golf courses can provide
real solutions we've also got a lot of
water withdrawal issues Connecticut golf
courses have come under a lot of
restrictions we don't get the intensity
of drought that you get out west right
of course nowhere near that but what
we're experiencing now Mateo is this
very interesting episodic thing if you
look back at I showed a graph earlier
before you joined us it rained about an
inch and a half on May 29th and it
hasn't really rained much since then and
so we've gone about three and a half
weeks now again three and a half weeks
out west is nothing you guys are that's
like oh it would take rain every three
weeks as like heaven out here this is
where we start to throw more water get
more hand watering when we think about
some of the challenges back East here
wedding agents are going to be an
opportunity I'm a little concerned about
more acreage being irrigated that's got
to get your attention a little bit what
are you talking to guys like Elliot and
some of the other senior directors here
in the East about these things is there
any discussion of what we should be
thinking about in support of this I know
you're focused out west but everybody
and their brothers started oh I got you
know this makes your water wetter or
inject this thing into your water what
other kinds of things you think in
places like the Northeast might be
useful for us to start to consider
yeah definitely you know like as as you
said my my Premier uh focus is here in
the southwest but my position is
actually at the at the national level so
you know like I'm uh we are looking to
help
um all the courses even the one on the
east end and as you pointed out um we
we're noticing you know like Texas or
other parts of this of the country where
they're going to teach episode of of
drought so having a plant is is really
essential
um like you know you have the one on
your on your website and it looks like
it's pretty uh easy and simple to use
but how you know I have an idea of of
what you um need to irrigate and what
you have to do when you're asked to
reduce or like or if you will go dry or
if you can only hand water you know like
maybe this time that you have to uh
limit your irrigation just to the teas
and the in the in the greens and let the
Fairway is in the Rascal you know like
generally you know the the rough if you
have a separate irrigation system you
can control that you can do that
um and also keep in mind that grass is
pretty resilient probably like
um some of the species that we're using
you know they're um very drought
tolerant to a level you know that we
really don't give too much credit for
and also the the recuperative capacity
of that Kentucky Bluegrass you know with
the with the rhizomes once the rain come
back once the drought is over it is
really able to regenerate
um and if you have rye grass you know
like a reseeding and probably uh putting
out one of the new cultivars that
they've been
bred with fundings from from the USGA
from the Davis program you know the the
Breeders have been doing a tremendous
job on producing new cultivars with more
drought tolerance so you know just just
just kind of BB radio you know and don't
be afraid to um
to cut the irrigation a little bit
because your grass will survive your
golf course will come back so one aspect
of your work is is you know getting new
technologies out into the hands of folks
and um we were really fortunate a few
years ago uh to put some subsurface
irrigation
on some peas out in Martha's Vineyard
um we had a I think we met with you uh
and and uh Barrett a number of years ago
before we did this and it's pretty
astounding how much water you save we
put about five inches of sand and then
the subsurface irrigation how has it I
mean to me this seems like a no-brainer
you worked on this for a long time even
with crappy water right I mean you guys
got in many cases you're doing this for
crappy water talk to our listeners a
little bit about that this could work
for us in the Northeast especially on
flat isolated tees where you got one big
head that's throwing water you know a
hundred yards away when all the wind is
talk a little bit about your experience
did you get a lot of adoption of this
out west uh what are some of the
obstacles and keys because guys will say
ah I can't verify ah you know I don't
know if it's working right right so talk
a little bit about your experience with
subsurface irrigation yeah so we really
started you know 20 years ago or even
you know more than that uh New Mexico
state with Dr banley now where we
already took subsurface drip uh and and
have all the possible testing sailing
irrigation establishment fertilizing pgr
application you you name it and then
um it really picked up when the golf
course uh um the golf club the last
campanas in Santa Fe they were
uh their water was keep getting higher
and higher they wanted to start reducing
how much water they were going to pay
and use for and so they they they looked
it up online you know different
strategies they found us and so we went
out there and did like 12 teas on
subsurface drip
hey what we found is that you know it
works it it's the grass is staying alive
they're using 50 to 80 percent of water
and these we place water meter in there
so you know it was it was calculated
it's not it was just a quick estimate
um and the the the other benefits was
just in reducing maintenance you know
the with these Island tea a lot of water
was was getting sprayed outside and
um and then the crew had to go and trim
down that all of the vegetation so
that's the thing now I was I was there a
few weeks ago and they're up to over 20
keys they converted on their own Caesar
was outside of the project and same you
know with the help of our agronomists
here in the southwest
we are
um promoting it a little bit more you
know Brian Whitlock he's really adamant
about you know putting it onto these
Island teas to just to save water reduce
the the overspray and and the growth so
we slowly starting to pick up it's one
of those things you know like you know
the the golfing is better than I do but
you know superintendent they talk to
each other you know if something is
working for a course who's going to tell
their friends and then their friends are
going to tell other friends you know we
can publish paper we can write
scientific articles nobody is going to
care about beside the scientific
Community but a golf course you know is
going to care about what his friend down
the road have done and it's experiment
and starting to adopt and so slowly
we're seeing we actually just um
um working on on you know on those on
those playbooks you know one of the
aspects of that is subsurface drip so
trying to give out some instruction to
these facilities to start to implement
them a little bit more uh and also as a
as a part of this program uh we have
we're doing projects where um we're
trying to take this technology into
larger areas So the plan is to do from T
all the way to Green we're not
comfortable doing greens yet uh but
we're gonna take two three
even more Fairways uh with the courses
that want to work with us and we're just
going to do the entire thing and see how
it works you know we don't know if it's
going to be a feasible solution but we
know that it's delivering water better
more uniform hopefully we're going to
have better plane conditions and on the
on the and the end result is using less
water yeah and and we you know we got a
name for that overspray we call it
fugitive water because out in the
vineyard where they can't use herbicides
uh on the golf course that was exactly
what was happening The Fugitive water
was escaping weeds were growing like
crazy and they don't have herbicides to
deal with them so this was part of an
overall pesticide use reduction strategy
as much as water savings and Carl just
like that we've used up to 30 minutes is
there any pressing questions for Dr
Serena otherwise we'll thank them and
let them get back to his day yeah just I
just want to highlight one one thing you
said is is that uh the case studies sort
of golf course is doing it is really
where you start to drive adoption and
awareness and we've tried to do that
with our resources we've tried to be
case study focused and Golf Course
focused with the vineyard club with
Bethpage State Park and some of our New
York state parks that's where I think
we'll start to see some of the adoptions
so as superintendents work through this
they really sort of Drive the the
adoption of the new technologies and
that and I think that's a great approach
The Playbook approach to getting golf
courses to do it thanks for taking the
time Mateo thank you great to see you
it's I appreciate it and congratulations
on the job and you're welcome thanks
Partners up here in the Northeast to
work with you yeah excellent thanks a
bunch Mateo everybody uh thanks for
another good uh another season Turf Show
this is the finale today thanks to all
our listeners and viewers uh wherever
you're getting this podcast YouTube
webinar uh we'll see you again probably
next year maybe another one in the
summer who knows uh but until then take
care thanks everybody see you Carl bye
Mateo bye this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu you